- ♪ Something spiritual ♪
♪ Something spiritual ♪
Bonjour! Ça va bien?
- Je suis super content
de vous rencontrer parce que
vous avez un nouveau
spectacle, "Créature".
- Oui.
- Toujours dans l'objectif
de démocratiser la drag.
La drag, ça peut être tout
et n'importe quoi. Qu'est-ce
que vous avez voulu faire?
JEAN-FRANÇOIS GUÈVREMONT,
connu sous le nom de Rita Baga
- Bien, ce que je voulais faire,
c'est surtout sortir la drag des
bars. Donc, d'un milieu assez
hermétique, dans les grandes
villes, fermé, pour les adultes
seulement. Là, ce que j'avais
envie, c'est de partir à la
rencontre de la famille. Donc,
c'est vraiment de 7 à 177 ans.
Tout est possible.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La drag, ça peut être très
physique. Alors, est-ce que
Rita Baga s'entraîne? Et comment
elle développe son talent?
- L'entraînement, c'est toujours
un défi. En fait, là, je suis
en train de m'installer un gym
à la maison. Confidence sauvage.
- Sauvage?
- Sauvage. Mais sans blague,
c'est vraiment rendu un
entraînement, ce spectacle-là.
Je bois six bouteilles d'eau
pendant le spectacle. Je sue.
Et c'est très physique.
Je suis seule sur scène.
Mes changements de costumes
se font en bas de deux...
En fait, en bas de 1 minute 40.
J'ai mon conjoint qui est
sur la scène avec moi,
qui coproduit le spectacle
aussi, qui est mon habilleur
pendant le spectacle et aussi
régisseur, donc c'est vraiment
comme une histoire de famille,
ce spectacle là, c'est très
physique.
- Rita Baga, il fallait une
bonne dose de courage en 2007,
pour Jean-François Guèvremont,
pour créer Rita Baga, envers
et contre tous. J'aimerais
savoir ce qui s'est passé
dans votre tête à l'époque.
- Bien, pour moi, en 2007,
quand je l'ai fait, c'était
pour la fête d'une amie drag.
Et c'était l'histoire d'un soir.
Et finalement, je me suis fait
prendre au jeu. Je suis tombée
dedans. J'ai eu la piqûre
tout de suite. Et après ça,
ça a été... quand j'ai pris ça
plus au sérieux, ça a été
comme un deuxième "coming out".
Il a fallu que je l'annonce
à ma famille, mes amis.
- Un "coming out" pour annoncer
que vous êtes drag?
- Oui. Et ça a eu un effet
plus grand que mon "coming out"
comme personne queer parce que
les gens avaient les mêmes
stéréotypes, les préjugés
que j'avais sur ce métier-là,
c'est-à-dire que c'est... ça se
fait dans les bars seulement.
Donc, là, c'est toutes
des personnes qui consomment,
qui travaillent pas de jour.
Ça dort toute la journée.
J'avais beaucoup d'appréhensions
et de préjugés. Et ma famille,
mes amis aussi, donc il a fallu
l'expliquer et longtemps,
je l'ai caché que je faisais
de la drag. J'ai fait des études
jusqu'à la maîtrise.
Je le disais pas à mes collègues
d'études.
- Des études en quoi?
- J'ai de maîtrise en gestion,
développement du tourisme.
Puis j'ai décidé de le dire,
en fait, quand il y a eu
"Ils de jour, elles de nuit",
un documentaire à ICI ARTV.
Parce que là, on me voyait
carrément en Rita et en Jean-
François. Et depuis ce temps-là,
on dirait que quelque chose
s'est connecté. Là,
je n'ai plus besoin de séparer
nécessairement mes deux vies.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Vous vous êtes dévoilée
dans "Canada's Drag Race",
dans aussi l'émission
"Big Brother Célébrités".
Rita Baga, lorsqu'elle retourne
à la maison, loin de la scène,
elle doit vivre avec
Jean-François Guèvremont,
son créateur, depuis 2007.
Comment ça se passe, tout ça?
- Moi, j'aime beaucoup
le fait d'avoir l'espèce
d'armure qu'est Rita pour...
ouvrir des portes.
En fait, je dis souvent :
défoncer les portes plus que
les ouvrir. Ou briser certains
plafonds de verre. J'aime
beaucoup le... l'espèce
de pouvoir qui vient avec
mon personnage de Rita, puis
rendu à la maison, j'apprécie
la tranquillité et je suis pas
quelqu'un qui fait des bains
de foule ou qui aime ça,
se faire reconnaître. Ça me gêne
souvent plus qu'autre chose.
Donc, être à la maison,
tranquille, je fais mon petit
jardinage. J'écoute mes
programmes sur ma tablette.
Je suis quand même assez
casanière quand je peux l'être,
mais en même temps, j'ai
toujours beaucoup de projets
en même temps.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il n'y a pas si longtemps.
vous disiez que la drag,
c'était un à-côté, un passe-
temps. Vous aviez un autre
emploi ailleurs. Là, ce n'est
plus le cas, j'imagine.
C'est à temps plein.
- Ce n'est plus le cas,
effectivement, depuis décembre
l'an dernier. En fait, j'ai déjà
longtemps fait deux emplois
à temps plein. J'étais directeur
de la programmation pour le
festival Fierté Montréal de jour
et le soir, et parfois même
de jour, j'étais aussi Rita.
Donc, j'ai été longtemps dans un
espèce de combinaison d'horaire,
80 h en semaine, pas beaucoup
de sommeil. Je dirais pas que
j'ai plus de sommeil maintenant,
mais j'ai beaucoup plus
d'opportunités comme Rita,
et je le dis toujours aux gens
qui hésitent avant de se lancer
dans leur passion, qu'on a juste
100 % d'énergie dans la vie
et 100% de temps, donc quand
on pense en pourcentage,
le pourcentage qu'on attribue
à un projet, bien c'est le
pourcentage de retour qu'on aura
par rapport à ce projet-là.
- Rita Baga, merci beaucoup pour
cette entrevue et bonne tournée!
- Merci!
♪ J'ai besoin de nous,
c'est comme ça ♪
♪ Même si ça joue